the cornelius gertian brought into
harbor and seized by french police who
say it has no licence to operate in
their waters
the owners say they have stuck to all
rules but their boat is caught in a much
bigger dispute frustration is giving way
to brinkmanship
it's not a war it's a fight the french
and the fishermen have rights an
agreement was signed and we must ensure
it is respected we have fishing rights
we must defend them and we are defending
them
here in berlin sumer fishing really is
the backbone of the community and plenty
here are happy to see the government
standing up for them
[Music]
about
foreign
france says that unless there is
progress on a deal it will stop british
boats from entering its ports plenty of
produce comes across the channel
stopping that flow would damage both
sides but the french are also
threatening more checks on freight going
in and out of the uk and that will mean
these cues getting even worse
and it is that specter of supply chains
being squeezed even more ahead of
christmas that will fray tempers even
further
at first this looked like just another
squabble between the uk and the european
union but now it's grown into something
else a full-blown diplomatic battle
between the united kingdom and france
and if the french do go ahead with their
threats to ban british fishing vessels
or to gum up customs checks at ports
like halle
that would be incendiary would have big
repercussions on both sides of the
channel
the reality is that this is a row about
a small slice of a small industry
fishing has long been a fault line in
brexit now it is cracking open
adam parsons sky news